we are on problem 63.
the height of a triangle is four inches
four inches greater than twice its base
let me draw this triangle in question
so let's see so let me draw that's the
triangle
that's its height that's its base so it
says the height is four so this is the
base let's say this is the base let's
call that b
so then the height
that's that the height is four inches
greater than twice its base so four
inches more
than two times the base fair enough the
area of the triangle is 168 square
inches what is the base of the triangle
so what's the area of a triangle it's
the base
times the height times one
so area is equal to one-half
base times height well they told us that
the height is equal is four more than
twice the base so we could just
substitute that in and then we'll just
have a
we'll have it just in terms of the base
let me keep that there so the area
is equal to one-half the base times the
height which they told us is four more
than twice the base
and now if we distribute the one-half b
we get
area is equal to one half b times four
is equal to two b
and then one half b times two b that's
plus
b squared right right one half times two
is one and then b times b is b squared
fair enough
and they tell us that the area is 168.
okay so we have
area is 168
and that's equal to 2 times the base
plus the base squared
let's swap the sides just to make it
look a little bit familiar b squared
plus two times the base is equal to one
hundred sixty eight
see we could subtract 168 from both
sides you get b squared plus two b
minus 168
is equal to zero
and 168's a bit of a strange number i
don't know exactly which numbers go into
168 let's see it looks like four
six four would go into it what four
would go into it forty
four no this four isn't going to work
let's see 12 goes into 168. see 44
12 does 12 go into it
yeah 12 goes into 168 and i think it
goes into it 14 times right so that
works so you could use a quadratic
equation to solve this but i think that
12 times 14 is 168 and they have to be
of different signs since this is a
negative right you have only different
signs when multiplied get you a negative
number and they're four apart they're
two apart so that works out so you get
b plus 14
times b
minus 12 is equal to zero and let me
just to confirm and not waste your time
14 times 12 i'm pretty sure i'm right
yeah 168.
i just factored that out so b could be
equal to minus 14 right that would make
that zero
or
b could be equal to 12 which would make
that zero obviously if you could make
one of these terms zero you're making
this whole thing zero
and the base since we're doing with you
know distances or lengths we can't have
a negative length so the base has to be
12 whatever 12 inches which is choice c
in that question right there
12 inches
next question
problem 64.
64.
all right
so they
this is a good one all right
what is that thing reduced to lowest
terms so essentially what they want to
do is factor stuff out and factor it out
and and write it as a
product of factor then cancel out the
ones so let's see what we can do can we
factor that top
expression
let's see this is this looks like a
perfect square right because
if you have
minus 2y squared is 4y squared and minus
2y minus 2i is minus 4y so this should
be the top expression
is
x minus 2 y
squared and i'll just write it twice
because i'm i'm guessing that one of
them are going to have to be factored
out x minus 2 i
and once again the intuition is is that
let's see i have if i had this
x squared minus four x plus four you say
okay what times what two numbers when
you multiply them equal four and when
you add them equal minus four you say oh
minus two and you'd say oh that's equal
to x minus two
and x minus two right the only
difference between that and that is they
put y's here
y and a y squared
and then you say okay so let's treat
four y so you could you could visualize
this thing as x squared minus four y
x
plus 4
y
squared
right or you could visualize this as x
squared minus 2 times 2 y
x
plus
2 y
squared right oh this isn't 4y squared
it's 4
y squared forget the parentheses but i
hope you can see that this thing up here
is the same thing as this thing right
here
and that's where i got the intuition
that that's going to be x minus 2i times
x minus 2y right you say okay what two
numbers when you add them they're 2
times 2i well obviously 2y and what
numbers when you square them is 2y
squared well 2y times 2i is 2y squared
so that's why you where you get the
intuition that's x minus 2y times x
minus 2y all right that's the numerator
and let's see what we can do with the
denominator
the denominator well immediately both
factors are divisible by 3 and both
factors are divisible both terms are
divisible by y so let's factor those out
so this is equal to 3y
now if you divide this term by 3y all
you're left with is an x right 3xy
divided by 3y you just have an x
and then if you divide minus 6y squared
by 3y you're left with
6 divided by
minus 6 divided by 3 is minus 2 y
squared divided by y is y
and let's see if we assume that x does
not equal 2y right because then this
would be undefined we can cancel these
two out and you're just left with x
minus 2y
over 3y
and that is choice
b
problem 65
problem 65 they want us to do it again
okay let's see
they want us to do it again
so this top expression let's see
everything's divisible by three so let's
let's rewrite it let's factor out a
three there so it'd be three times two x
squared
plus seven x right 21 divided by three
plus seven x plus three
let's see what's the bottom one well
this is a pattern a squared minus b
squared right a squared minus b squared
this is something squared 4x squared is
2x squared and then 1 is obviously 1
squared so we could write this as equal
as a plus b
times a minus b
and what that would be two x plus one
two x plus one
times two x minus one
right two x is two x squared is four x
squared and 1 squared is 1.
so let's see if we factor that top part
and i'm guessing it's going to cancel
out with something in the denominator so
let's see what we can get this is equal
to
let me do it on the side here
so if i had to factor
2 x squared plus seven x plus three
so it's going to be
two x
two x plus something
times x plus something
right because the 2x times the x is 2x
squared
and the b times the a is going to be
equal to 3
and already so i'm guessing one of them
is going to be a 3 and one of them is
going to be a 1.
and i could already guess if we could do
a little bit more systematically on how
this is going so let's multiply it out
2x 2x times x
2x squared
2x times a plus 2ax
b times x plus bx b times a plus ba
so you get 2x squared and i merge these
terms
add the coefficients plus
2a
plus b
x right that's those two terms
plus ba is equal to this thing up here
is equal to
i'll write it right below it so we can
compare terms is equal to 2 x squared
plus 7 x
plus 3.
so what could a and b equal
see 2 times a plus b is equal to
so if a is 3
if this is 3 and this is 1
2 times 3 is 6 plus 1 is 7 works and
then
3 times 1 is 7. so b is
1 and a is 3.
so this is a 3 and this is a
1. and you could multiply that out if
you're not comfortable with it but
anyway we could rewrite this top thing
as
three times and we did the factoring
here we figured out that b and a are
two x plus one
times x plus three
all of that over
2x plus 1 times 2x minus 1 and we know
we're on the right track because we've
got something to cancel out and
sure enough so we cancel those out
assuming that this never equals zero
this x does not equal minus one half
because that would make that equal zero
and we get three
times x plus three
over
two x minus one
and that is
choice b
choice b let me see the next problem see
if we have time to do it right now
oh it's another one of these i'll wait
for the next video see you soon